Jimmy was on last night saying he was
real excited about me coming on yeah he
was reading the but here's what he said
I really was very moved by this I'm
reading the the the the chapter I was
underlining that stuff and the plane
takes off and I'm reading what he writes
the intros to all these chapters and
this is the nicest things about me like
and I got emotional I kind of toyed
ivana said I teared up you know I got I
started crying a little bit cuz I was
like this is the nice thing that's said
about me and really and as we took off I
looked down and there was ink all over
the feet my pen exploded blotches all
over my chapter so I'm going on there
tonight I think this is expectation that
I'm gonna go on and it's gonna be the
greatest wildest thing ever people don't
need you to be the wildest greatest
thing ever they want to see you in
another setting where you might they
might see something different about you
listen they're gonna get something
different I've been up since 3:30 in the
morning